420 gigatonnes de dioxyde de carbone
c'est environ ce qui reste de notre
budget carbone mondiale si on y met plus
de co2 x on risque fort d'un réchauffer
le climat au dessus de 1,5 degré celsius
et subir les pires conséquences du
dérèglement climatique
on a une limite assez clair pour guider
nos efforts de réduction des émissions
de gaz à effet de serre ça devrait être
cinq de se partager le travail non ben
non pas vraiment
comment on détermine la juste part de
chaque pays dans la lutte climatique
c'est la question à mille milliards de
dollars est-ce qu on répartit les forts
selon la taille la population en
fonction du pib en fonction des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre on est
devant le plus gros travail d'équipé que
l'humanité a eu à rentrer et qui dit
travail d'équipé dit souvent injustice
la chine par exemple elle est depuis
2007 le plus gros émetteur de ges mais
si on divise ses émissions là par tête
de pipe on voit qu'une canadienne et
mais plus qu'une chinoise maintenant
disons qu'on imagine dans le monde où il
ya ni frontière ni pays et qu'on les
parties tout ce qui reste du budget
carbone entre tous les terrains en
théorie chaque personne pourrait émettre
jusqu'à 50 capes tonnes d'équivalent co2
avant qu'on épuise notre budget
pour la population canadienne ça
voudrait dire que notre part du budget
restant serait limitée à 2025 mégatonnes
mais en réalité on émet environ 730
mégatonnes par an de quoi remplir plus
de 200000 tas de l'ain pic de co2 à ce
rythme là on défend serait le budget qui
nous est alloué pour moins de 3 ans bien
plutôt qu'un grand nombre de pays qui
met pas mal moins que nous c'est entre
autres parce qu on est peu nombreux
qu'on doit circuler sur un grand
territoire et parce que le canada est le
quatrième producteur de pétrole au monde
malgré l'objectif de carboneutralité
pour 2050 si on brûle le pétrole et le
gaz qu'on prévoit actuellement extraire
sur le territoire canadien ces émissions
la équivalent à 16 % du budget mondial
restant
mais notre carte ati aussi historique
depuis la révolution industrielle il ya
plusieurs pays qui se sont enrichis tout
en émettant beaucoup de co2 bien avant
que des pays comme l'inde ou la chine
deviennent des puissances économiques
pour tenir compte de la responsabilité
présentes et passées des pays les plus
industrialisés on peut faire appel au
système de contraction et convergence
selon ce principe les résultats
devraient réduire drastiquement leurs
émissions plus vite que les pays les
moins avancés il faudrait aussi qui est
plus nanti des dommages les pays qui
subissent les effets du réchauffement de
plein fouet qui se trouvent souvent à
être ceux qui ont le moins contribué au
problème
le hic c'est que certains pays ont du
mal à reconnaître pleinement leurs
responsabilités pour des raisons
politiques mais aussi pour des raisons
de gros sous de très gros sous pour
financer l'adaptation des états qui ont
pratiquement pas émis de ge s il faudra
mettre plusieurs centaines de milliards
de dollars dans la cagnotte c'est le
grand défi de chaque conférence des
parties sur les changements climatiques
comme celles de glasgow accouché d'un
budget hors dollars le plus équitable
possible pour éviter de défoncer notre
budget en carbone et ratifié le tout
dans un accord contraignant
contrairement à l'accord de paris où
chaque état décider de ce qui est juste
pour lui-même avec des actions fait sur
une base volontaire
les changements climatiques sont déjà là
plus le temps passe plus et des gosses
s'accumulent et plus la facture est
salée mais on arrive à un moment très
intéressant de l'histoire celui où les
coûts de production d'énergie
renouvelable sont enfin compétitif
il reste que pour changer la donne et
parvenir à une justice climatique il va
falloir que tous s'y mettent